[Musique]
le centre ville de montréal renaît peu à
peu les jours de semaine on le constate
aux heures de pointe dans les rues sur
les trottoirs et aussi dans le métro où
l'achalandage représente maintenant 53%
puisqu'il était en 2019 on le voit aussi
le midi dans certaines foires
alimentaires comme ici au pied de la
place ville-marie très content de voir
des collègues revoir un peu de la vie
des restos manger autre chose que du
surgelé à la maison c'est génial ça fait
du bien de revoir des gens d'entendre du
bruit ça fait du bien pour l'esprit
d'équipé sont on voit quelqu'un beaucoup
de plus de synergie maintenant avec avec
les équipes dans lesquelles on travaille
selon la chambre de commerce de montréal
environ 50 mille travailleurs se déplace
actuellement au centre ville chaque jour
alors qu'ils étaient 350 milles avant la
pandémie dans les chiffres qu'on voit
c'est une progression du nombre
d'employés qui ont amorcé leur retour on
est rendu à 61 pour ça on est à 47 %
nous est à 28 % en juin c'est pas tous
les jours c'est souvent une fois par
semaine des fois même une fois par deux
semaines
la consigne de privilégier le
télétravail est maintenant levé et la
plupart des entreprises mettent en
oeuvre leur plan de retour ce 21
novembre le constructeur pomerleau
souhaitait la bienvenue à ses employés
ils doivent désormais passer une ou deux
journées par semaine au bureau jordi
lama venait déjà sur une base volontaire
deux ou trois jours par semaine je
comptage pense que le retour au travail
au fait du bien au niveau mental je
pense que le mode hybrid vont remettre
un mode qui vont être parfait pour pour
moi personnellement je pense qu'il ya
des points positifs
avoir une certaine flexibilité
chez pomerleau les prochains mois
serviront à expérimenter les nouveaux
horaires hybrides des 300 employés
éventuellement ce qu'on vise le fait
d'avoir nous envoyer trois jours par
semaine au bureau et je pense que c'est
une option qui est viable à long terme
parce que ça permet je crois
suffisamment collégialité proximité puis
en même temps
il ya des tâches qu'on fait plus de
façon plus efficace quand on est
concentrés chez soi les entreprises sont
d'ailleurs nombreuses à envisager un
avenir hybrides chez hydro québec par
exemple où les 7000 employés du
centre-ville reviendront graduellement
en janvier pour les premières semaines
de leur présence au bureau va être
acquise une journée par semaine minimum
et ensuite on va déployer le programme
d'été le travail qui va être flexible et
brident selon les différentes fonctions
de chacun mais en moyenne ça va être un
trois jours de travail par semaine
la caisse de dépôt demandera elle trois
jours par semaine en présentiel à ses
employés les mardis et mercredis seront
obligatoires pour que tout le monde se
retrouve à la sun life les 2200 employés
auront carte blanche aucune obligation
de venir travailler sur place le
décrochage anticipé lost à peu près 25%
à terme une étude commandée par la
chambre de commerce démontre que le
centre ville pourrait perdre un
travailleur sur quatre à cause du
télétravail pour les petits commerçants
qui souffre déjà c'est une donnée
inquiétante quand on regarde dans les
galeries marchandes on est à 34%
d'ouverture donc c'est un commerce sur
trois au pied des tours à bureaux dans
les espaces c'est 40 % à peu près et
durant l'année ce qui est inquiétant
c'est que ça a diminué malgré la relance
post pandémique il y a aujourd'hui 4 % -
de petits commerces ouverts au
centre-ville qu'il y en avait au début
de l'année ce que ça témoigne c'est ce
qu'on avait anticipé ces cliques
commerçants se rendent un peu au bout de
leur énergie au bout de leurs liquidités
et finissent par tomber dans certains
cas il ya les boulettes de viande il ya
des spaghettis lp store le petit
restaurant de rhinau machinerie rue
stanley existe depuis 28 ans et l'hiver
qui s'en vient sera critique
malheureusement c'est un corps gras
qu'il dise on fait un moyenne 17,8
clients par jour au lieu d'avoir 35 aux
trente jeunes chats ce que le
propriétaire disant comprendre tout ça
il me reste respirer mais il y en a au
moins une bonne nouvelle pour lui selon
la chambre de commerce bien des
travailleurs qui reviennent au centre
ville en profiteront pour dépenser
presque autant d'argent qu'avant mais en
moins deux jours